[Music]  in my lifetime I've only fallen in love  twice the first time led to betrayal  murder and suicide the second time would  prove far more tragic  my name is Baron Juliet you told you  your name please  centuries ago I told someone the story  of my heartbreak  he was an English writer he took my  story and published it and made it one  of the most famous love stories ever  told  at the end of the play she killed myself  that part is true or at least I tried  that's when he turned me the one we call  father  [Music]  I'm not trying to replace him your love  was real but if it was  once-in-a-lifetime then why am I having  those exact same feelings for someone  else  do you really think that I was gonna let  you get away with that American Girl  with my bloodline someone helps me home  and you want me to take life I want you  to be with a minute  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you